we met one time before
and
you can't remember it you don't know
when you met me when do we meet steve
well i got i i gotta hear this one man
because it's like i i met you before
it wasn't like uh
we got to know each other very well we
were and there's a photo of it that's
hilarious we were in a las vegas
nightclub
i want to say it was it was 2013. so
about eight years ago there's photos of
us in a booth and in the photos i
remember meeting you i remember meeting
you inside of the nightclub wow
i forgot about that
in the photo in this booth or whatever
at this table there's me
you
tom green
carrot top
chris angel right all five of us maybe
someone else i don't know dude it was
the funniest [ __ ] guess what i got that
photo too but it's
in one of my other phones my other old
phones did and said it was wow
you just bought it back bro yeah we
partied man we party party scott you
know what i'm saying in the whole night
cause i could matter of a fact i
happened to be there that night with
chris
i was hanging out with chris that night
chris angel yeah you know yeah cause
that's one of my good friends yeah i
love chris angel yes he's the best man
yeah i love me some chris bear you know
and his and his son johnny christopher
you know what i'm saying i was doing
shows with tom green cute little boy man
yeah tom green and i were double
headlining we had a little red residency
going at the riviera tom green is my boy
yeah he's a good guy tom green's a
talented rapper yes he is
yeah yeah yeah he kind of picked he kind
of picked up some of the some of the
habits
yeah now let me ask you this flav did
you ever hear about the time when i was
trying to be a rapper no
no
everyone we asked i never knew that i
knew you was always a jackass but not a
rapper
yeah what was your album called
hard as a rock
wow sounds like a dick man
because these are hard as rocks
did gangsters want to be hard right and
cox want to be hard no doubt
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude